he's been called the world's most
repulsive politician his controversial
statements have been described as sexist
homophobic and racist his government's
recent attempts to alter data related to
the corona virus have lent credibility
to those who had previously called him
authoritarian all of these criticisms
and more had already been leveled as I
gear ball scenario before late 2018 when
he won the Brazilian presidential
election in a landslide so how did he do
it
bolson ro has made a career of having
this personality that's this very alpha
male macho I'm gonna show you refusing
to bow down to critics kind of attitude
a lot of people make a comparison to
Bolton arrows rise to the rise of Trump
in a broad-brush kind of way that is a
totally fair comparison it was a
populist movement that swept bowls in
Ireland to office and it was a rejection
of the status quo so that's a honor to
give that to you thank you very much but
this comparison may not give both
scenarios own electoral success enough
credit whereas Donald Trump won the US
election while losing the popular vote
bolson ro was elected with around 55% of
the vote in the final round
unfortunately for him that popularity
stands in stark contrast to today he now
faces an economic crisis cratering poll
numbers and a corona virus outbreak that
is the worst in the region the question
now is whether bolson ro can leverage
his outspoken style an army of dedicated
supporters to salvage his presidency
Shire bolsa motto grew up with five
brothers in the southern brazilian town
of el dorado after two years in Rio de
Janeiro City Council he began his 27
year career in Congress and his ascent
to national fame during this time he
would cement some of his beliefs in the
public eye on crime he said in 2017 a
policeman who doesn't kill isn't a
policeman on LGBT rights he said in 2011
no father is capable of loving a gay son
he told a fellow member of Congress that
he would not rape her because she was
too ugly
in July of 2018 he announced his
candidacy for president would the slogan
Brazil above everything God above
everyone he proved immediately adept at
building an unprecedented coalition of
voters that grouping of the alpha male
firearm ownership the evangelical and in
the military that has become his base
and they didn't used to be together so
he's truly transformed the landscape of
Brazilian politics in in a way that it's
hard to see that going away
Paul senado also picked the perfect time
to portray himself as the Anti
Corruption candidate operation car wash
the largest anti-corruption effort in
Brazil's history had begun only a few
years before and had since ensnared many
important figures in the country's
political Left including two former
Brazilian presidents bolson ro took
office as the 38th president of Brazil
at the beginning of 2019 he immediately
made good on one campaign promise
stripping Brazil's indigenous Affairs
agency of the responsibility to identify
and demarcate indigenous lands
indigenous people in Brazil for several
decades have been really aggressively
pushing to get legal rights to their
land and title he specifically said when
he was running for election that if he
was elected he would not allow
indigenous people to get any more land
in Brazil and basically would shut down
all of those processes and that was the
first thing he did when he came into
office which is very symbolic way to
indicate what your position is when the
Amazon experienced record-breaking
wildfires in mid 2019 balsan Otto
downplayed the damage calling the data
lies and firing the head of the
government organization that produced it
after international outcry he dispatched
soldiers and allocated funds to fight
the fires but balsa narrows main focus
and what swept him into office was his
promise to kickstart Latin America's
largest economy but GDP in balsa narrows
first year in office grew at only one
point one percent down from 1.3 percent
in each of the previous two years his
signature accomplishment thus far has
been a pension reform bill that was
passed with congressional approval he's
also spent his time in office
stoking increasingly larger fights with
the press food the relationship with the
media is really antagonistic in a way
that hasn't been seen before and at a
temperature level that hasn't been seen
before
also naira stimulates his supporters to
fight with journalists every day it's
the escalation of problems and
aggressivity in front of his residence
because of that all important TVs
channel and newspapers who spam this
coverage because it became so aggressive
now Paul scenario faces a host of
problems threatening his administration
he has created a political crisis on top
of a public health crisis and a looming
economic crisis most economists forecast
that Latin America is headed into a
terrible scenario for the next year
possibly the next decade he has
multiplied the crises by pushing people
out of his own government out of his own
cabinet Brazil has one of the highest
death tolls of any nation from
coronavirus and on many days has the
most confirmed new cases of any country
in the world balsan ro has refused to
endorse social distancing and expressed
enthusiasm for using chloroquine to
treat the virus in early June
Boston Earls government was accused of
trying to cover up data related to the
corona virus when the Health Ministry
pulled the entire historic database fork
over 19 from its website the ministry
has since relented and republished some
historical information and made a
growing backlash
the president has downplayed the threat
of the virus calling it just a little
flu and very infrequently Danza masks
the president in Brazil doesn't have
power to lock down and forbidden the
shops and commerce here the example of
Busan ro is really strong thousands of
people's follow Busan ro and when he
said it's it's a necessary to smash
thousands of people followed but even
putting aside his handling of Brazil's
corona virus outbreak another threat
looms in the resignation of his justice
minister Sergio Moro Moro is a national
hero in Brazil having been the head
investigated judge for operation car
wash flash-forward to morrow resigning
and in his resignation claiming the
reason he was resigning was because of
corrupt practices of the President
that's totally damning to the
credibility of Bernardo the short
version is that Mauro said that he
caught bolson ro trying to pressure him
to change the head of the police chief
of Rio de Janeiro and the head of police
for the federal government
mara believes the reason bohlson ro was
pushing to make those changes is because
both scenarios own children his three
sons are under investigation for
criminal acts in Rio de Janeiro and at
the federal level Mauro and bolson aryl
have declined to comment for this video
in Boston ro and his sons have
separately denied any wrongdoing in the
matter regardless balsa knows approval
rating has taken a hit in light of the
recent scandals his supporters loved him
there are diehard bull cenario fans in
Brazil and they truly believe that the
media is attacking him that all of the
criticisms are just trying to bring down
the only guy who is trying to get rid of
the corruption that Brazil has been
riddled with for the past several
decades
[Music]